the numbers show there is a major push
needed to get people vaccinated here
in clark county kate houston shows us
what's being done to
drive our vaccination numbers up so we
can also open to 100 percent
getting a covic 19 vaccine just became
as easy as going through a drive through
starting tomorrow all you have to do is
pull up in your car and roll up your
sleeve
as clark county experiences a decline in
covid 19 vaccinations the southern
nevada health district is working to
make the process
even more convenient on tuesday
drive-through vaccination appointments
can be made at the convention center
this new clinic is in addition to
multiple pop-ups happening this week
clark county is currently 47 percent
vaccinated
in order for social distancing and
capacity restrictions to be removed
it needs to reach 60 percent greg castle
with the health district says vaccine
appointments declined
faster than expected which means it
could take longer
to reach that threshold we could be
looking at 10 weeks or more
before we actually get across that
finish line and what that means is
casino capacity theater capacity
stadiums arenas everything capacity wise
will not get to 100 percent by the by
the rules have been laid out by the
county
and i believe the state also has a hand
in that until we reach that mark
due to the slowdown in vaccinations
cashmen will close this wednesday
and unlv will close for first doses and
walk-ins on friday
moving forward castle says the health
district has a couple things in the
works
that could help bring in more people
they're expecting more information to be
released in the coming weeks
kate houston 8 news now now as mentioned
there are various pop-up vaccine clinics
happening at different times and
locations this week it changes all the
time so
for a current list of all that
information and also ways that you can
sign up at your local pharmacy make
appointments
you can head to our website at
8newsnow.com